the president and the harebrained people
around him are increasingly
fear-mongering around the stock market
saying if Biden wins in November say
goodbye to your 401ks here's actually a
tweet from Donald Trump yesterday where
he said quote if you want your 401ks and
stocks which are getting close to an
all-time high Nasdaq is already there to
disintegrate and disappear vote for the
radical left do-nothing Democrats and
corrupt Joe Biden massive tax hikes they
will make you very poor fast now I
already dealt yesterday with how the
overwhelming majority of Joe Biden's tax
increases go to the top one percent so I
don't want to get derailed here but
remember my segment about how populist
rhetoric can be used to bamboozle people
Trump ran with populist rhetoric he's
for the middle class and he's against
all the oppressive factors that are
oppressing the middle class Joe Biden's
gonna raise taxes on the very rich on
the top one percent and Trump populist
Trump is now campaigning against it and
scaring people about it doesn't sound
very populist to me does it anyway
that's not what I want to deal with
today I want to look at this claim Biden
would be bad for the stock market from a
few different angles now the the first
is just a reminder again they are lying
in the sense that the stock market does
better under Democratic presidents I
will get to that data in a moment but
the other side of this that I think is
always important to repeat when
something like this comes up is that the
Trump administration continues to say or
believe or claim or pretend that you can
measure how well an economy is doing by
looking at the stock market and you can
so before we even get into the numbers
of Democrats versus Republicans on the
stock market let me remind you stock
market performance does not tell you how
well the economy is doing stocks are
disproportionately owned by the wealthy
and by big corporations the more we
learn about how do we evaluate how well
or poorly an economy is doing we
understand that the stock market is a
component but it is merely one of many
components we should be looking at we
must look at the employment rate
and unemployment rate we have to look at
wage growth we have to look at the
quality of jobs we must look at
inflation and inequality and really you
want to look at quality of life factors
as well what is life expectancy
educational factors where is literacy
right there are so many ways to figure
out like how is a country doing a big
picture but let's for a second grant
them that there is an empirical reality
stock markets either do better under
Democratic presidential administrations
or Republican presidential
administrations we can measure it we can
know this there are a whole bunch of
different ways to do it so you've got to
make some decisions like I'll give you
some examples do you would just stock
market for a performance for inflation
or not when comparing Democratic and
Republican performance do you calculate
returns with dividends reinvested or not
okay so there's like little tweaks in
terms of how you calculate it no matter
how you do it every serious analysis
finds that stocks do better under
Democratic presidents than they do under
Republican presidents if you go back to
1929 on average stocks make about ten
percent a year during democratic
presidencies and about two percent a
year during Republican presidencies
that's one study from Forbes another
study that looked only at the last 45
years or so found that the stock market
return is about 14 percent per year
under Democratic presidents 10 percent
per year under Republican presidents now
the difficulty of these numbers is that
you can have sort of outlier years that
can skew the averages but from an
empirical historical perspective the
stock market does better when there's a
Democrat in the White House instead of a
Republican but that's looking back ok we
then should analyze if we want to do
this thoroughly would changing from
Trump to Biden likely raise the value of
stock prices lower the value or make no
change whatsoever very interesting new
research from JP Morgan which finds
that if you look at a Biden replacement
of Trump it would either be neutral or
slightly positive in terms of stock
prices and they also mentioned that
adding a quote diplomatic approach could
be good for stocks in that it would
reduce volatility now this is funny
because you know it's JP Morgan they're
trying to just make it adjust the facts
analysis they don't want to be political
diplomatic approach is a polite term for
Biden will be more normal
right Biden will not constantly do crazy
stuff markets like normal markets like
less volatility and the other component
that's more of an intangible if we think
about the effective Biden replacing
Trump on the stock market is a Biden
presidency would better deal with
coronavirus and because coronavirus is
really the major drag on the economy
right now there are additional benefits
we would expect to the economy from Joe
Biden taking over for Donald Trump we
interestingly we saw this under Bush
Obama the economy cratered under george
w bush of course 9/11 was a part of it
but certainly going to war with a
country that didn't attack us did not
help helped some defense stocks but it
did not help the economy overall
we saw the mortgage crisis devolve into
the 2007-2008 recession and then barack
obama came in and operated in January of
2009 and started to clean it up could
have better cleaned it up for sure
didn't do everything right but that was
the way when we could end up with a very
similar dynamic under Trump Biden if
Donald Trump is actually removed in
November and made a one-term president
not a guarantee but something that could
happen we could see a similar dynamic
where we see a proper economic recovery
once again under a Democratic president
it remains to be seen but the point is
the argument that Biden would be worse
for stocks than Trump it doesn't fit the
historical realities of stock markets
under Democrats versus Republicans and
it doesn't even pass the sniff test when
you think about replacing kooky wild
wacky Donald Trump with someone in Joe
Biden who
would be no progressive hero but would
certainly bring back diplomacy and bring
back some stability and bring back some
sanity big day
next Tuesday we've got two huge things
going on next Tuesday it will be the
third David Pakman show chess tournament
8 p.m. Eastern you can sign up now at
david pakman.com slash chess this is
totally free I will be playing we had
over seven 700 players during the June
tournament hope to do better than that
sign up for free at david pakman.com
slash chess number two we lost like 300
members in the last week because we had
a membership special last year when
those memberships came up for renewal
this year because of the virus a lot of
people couldn't afford to renew so sadly
we had like our worst 72 hours of my
pepper so next Tuesday the same day as
the chess tournament we're gonna do a
1-day membership special if you want to
be notified of it just get on my
newsletter at david pakman.com we'll
take a quick break and be back with much
more right after this